hi this is Nina today we're gonna make
chickpea salad this is a request from
Maria back in I don't know how long
so here we are this is my first time
making this so I don't know how it will
turn out but I think it's good to try
too because I liked your piece we make
sure piece maple mousse with chickpeas
sometimes Evans max a lot like and we
can check these you just mix it with the
herbs salt and pepper so thank you very
act for giving me this opportunity to
try it out and let's start so for this
recipe we need 16 ounces of chickpeas
and I make this a while back I froze it
so you just take it out whenever you
ready to eat if you don't like to make
it yourself you can always buy a can or
two from the grocery store so first I'm
going to join up the chippy then wash it
little bit put in this Cup
it has this outlet on the side so I need
16 ounces okay so dump it in this bowl
I'm gonna put everything in this bowl
the the nutrition and chickpeas it has
like a lot of iron you know it's good
for you and also have magnesium mp6 okay
so I'm going to dump it in here and also
we need 1/2 cup of red onions
going to chop this up like cutting
onions because it makes you cry first
I'm going to cut it in half and then cut
in another half make it colder okay
you're going to break it a little bit so
it's not a huge chunk so half it's about
half of the onions so now we're going to
add the cucumber's I don't have half of
the cucumber left so usually you can use
one cup of the the cucumbers it depends
on what you like
I've always divided into half and then
then I flip it over to cute this is 1/2
cup so to up the 1/2 cup and then next
we're gonna add some pepper green pepper
this is Evans favorite he really likes
peppers every kind of bothered green
peppers he never eats it I always have
to cut it up into slices and give it to
the put it in front of his face
see the shape of the cup of peppers
always cut in cut through these
and remove the seat okay so simply cut
the pepper and cube in size
okay so use one cup of peppers now I'm
going to add one cup of celery sticks I
like to buy the Costco one because it's
already washed so one cup
okay now we're going to add 1/2 cup of
cherry tomatoes well usually I cut it
like this but these nights are not
touched it's not a prett so I have to
cook like this just cut in half it's
fine you don't know what that is doing
in the background but you don't want to
know this is one cup we did another ok
so this is the 1/2 cup 1 and 1/2 cup
cherry tomatoes so right now I'm going
to ask them parsley put a cup of parsley
chop up the parsley find me very very
very tired
so 1/4 cup chopped
please check for more than quarter cups
so what're cups half cup of lemon juice
1/2 cup of lemon juice it's about you
large lemon so kendama missin so right
now we need 1/4 cup of virgin olive oil
then you can use one teaspoon of stuff
for me just to taste a little bit then
peppers have some grind fry some extra
sausage now mix it up you can add some
cheese in the recipes ad says some blue
cheese but we don't have blue cheese and
you don't like blue cheese I'm going to
add some chili pepper
I could eat spicy food but everything is
spicy so I'm just gonna take just a
little bit for flavor
so decide it's ready I think it looks
very pretty and it smells good too
I'm gonna actually taste it see how it
turned out
oh wow that's a great match mm-hmm I
don't know what I'm tasting each virus
favor in you yeah Wow
everything is amazing the lemon pops
Maria amazing work I'm loving it okay
well we're gonna recommend it decided
that you really liked it
I think I'm gonna eat that regularly
right now Thank You Maria for the
recommendation we really enjoyed the
salad for those who's watching please
like the video and comment below or you
can put any recommendation that what I
should make next see you next time
believed by distant prefer men okay now
you're out of frame now you got to come
back to noon ahead come back - hi hi
there you go see I'll just shrink down
is that gonna be raw onion
yes wrong are we gonna make out after
this I don't think I would want to make
up with you after you eat this
I really feel the onion the the wasn't
what is it the Isaac let's get into my
eyes already
okay haven't always said that I'm very
tiny stuff going on it's a Peter stop it
make my package
Hey look oh my god do you hear destinies
the whole house shirt tomatoes the
chickpeas block oh I love it all hmm
sorry I did put little too much stuff no
cuz I think Christina we should be like
a slow-motion replay when the in the
heart like this was going
okay so this is about 1 teaspoon that
was a teaspoon of salt we will add some
cherry great I tried to see there what
what cherry grapes creepster cherries
cherry tomatoes Oh
so I'm gonna dump this in oh I've got to
remove that pick it's all over here we
need a quick cut off virgin oil virgin
virgin oh hi everyone my name is Colette
Oh red I recommend that you try out Evan
Carmichael's newsletters they've helped
me to restart my business and realize my
passion which is awesome
you